jalisa I'm so pleased to meet you and
I'm so glad that we'll be able to have
this conversation this afternoon about
your book it's a very moving story I
found it so compelling and it obviously
is deeply personal that's what we'll
spend the most time on but it does touch
on some larger issues about aspects of
immigration in America today in
America's heritage so I hope we'll be
able to get to that as well but let's
begin at the beginning which of course
is the fact that you are from Mexico you
were born in Mexico and spent your early
childhood years there but it's
interesting that your childhood and how
you grew up isn't really the stereotype
you're not from an impoverished
background you were not from a small
isolated village could you talk to our
audience about your home your family the
circumstances of your upbringing yeah
thank you so much for for having me and
I'm excited to have this conversation I
grew up in Mexico and my family they
were they're all entrepreneurs and and
they worked really really hard to be
able to provide my siblings and I a
better life and even when we when I was
in Mexico I was really surrounded by a
really large support system because my
family is really close not just
emotionally close but we literally live
within walking distance from from each
other but my childhood in Mexico is was
very different than what a lot of people
have in their minds of how Mexican
children grow up what you what a lot of
tourists experience when they go to
Mexico and they see kids selling selling
gum on the side of on the side of the
road and that wasn't my experience
because my parents worked so hard and my
grandparents worked so hard to make sure
that that wasn't my experience so I grew
up in Mexico from middle income
I used to take piano lessons and karate
lessons and every kind of lesson that
was available in my small hometown but
that also came with sacrifice and the
biggest sacrifice that my parents were
making in order for me to have that kind
of life was that we weren't together my
parents lived in the US and I lived in
Mexico and we would only see each other
every few months or I would come to the
US and visit them in the summers well
tell us more about that the
circumstances of your parents deciding
to come to the US and to live apart from
their children what what how did you
experience that as a child what was that
what did what were you aware that that
was somewhat unusual
how did it feel yeah I was definitely
aware that that it was unusual because I
won I just I missed my parents and - I
could see parents coming with their
children to school to parent-teacher
conferences to different Mother's Day
events and my parents weren't there all
the time and they like I said they
wanted us to have a better life so they
when I was three years old they used to
import sterling silver into the US and
sell it at trade shows all across the
country and they will go back and forth
as part of their as part of their
business but you know as asked a little
girl as a child not having your parents
with you and only seen them every few
months first of all you feel like
they're a little bit of strangers to you
because when you when I when I would see
my parents they would come bearing lots
of presents and when I came to visit
them in the u.s. we were it was summer
vacation and so it was a very different
experience and having that having
parents who are with you every every
single day so it was and for me was also
really lonely experience because as
close as my family was my siblings my
two older sisters are five and ten years
older than me so it was it was very
difficult being being so alone at
early age and ultimately that's why my
parents decided to bring me to live with
them
they had they'd hit some hard financial
times and we're unable to go visit
Mexico as much and be with me as much
and because I was so young they realized
that that's not the best way to raise a
child and so that's when they decided to
bring me to live with them permanently
in the US and and that's where that's
where my life completely completely
changed well that's a very important and
very moving part of the book because it
is also accompanied by the fact that you
were the youngest child in the family
and so you really were a family favorite
in fact I love the place where you say
that you were a bit of a brat as a
youngster because you just had so much
your very gregarious and you loved to be
a performer and so forth and then and
then what happens your your your mother
has another child and I believe you're
nine years old and suddenly you have a
younger brother and it's a little bit of
a different dynamic isn't it yeah I mean
I you know my little brother and I have
a great relationship now but I think
when he when I found out that my mom was
pregnant with my little brother in
Mexico we have a saying that when you're
the favorite child you sit on the donkey
and and that comes from from the Bible
of Mary sitting on the donkey yes they
were walking through the desert to
Bethlehem and and so my whole family
would tease me about getting kicked off
the donkey because my little brother
would now have that place and not only
that but but in my mind as a ten year
old girl this baby was going to not only
take my parents love from me but he
would get he or she I didn't know at the
time it was gonna be a boy but I thought
but they would get to live with my
parents in America and then I found out
he's a boy and then being just keeps
getting worse in like my ten-year-old
mind because it's a really big deal to
have
a male baby in in in my culture and
Mexican family so that's a lot to take
in asked a little girl and that cope
with the fact that my sister's because
they were older they were now going to
college and in high school in a
different City so before I at least had
my sisters with me in Pasco and all of a
sudden my mom was having a new baby my
sisters were were going going to live in
a different city so then I felt not just
abandoned by my parents but now but my
sisters - and that was else a lot for me
to handle at that early age well so in
the middle of all of that emotional
turmoil and and what as you say a
ten-year-old mind it's very difficult to
understand these things your parents
decide that in fact you should come to
the United States and you do which under
these circumstances if when we're
writing a fairy tale it would be okay
and they lived happily ever after but we
all know that reality is different and
you describe a reality then that is
certainly different tell us about that
reality of coming to the United States
and then being here rather than in Tesco
with your family with larger family yeah
yeah so i i i didn't really didn't to
know that I was coming to live here I
when I came to visit that summer I
thought it was just like any other
summer when I came to visit my parents
and they would go back to Mexico once
the school year started but that summer
I ever went back and it was it was a
really difficult transition for me
because I think a lot of people can
relate to the fact that when you're a
kid one of the most scary things to do
is to go to a new school and have to
make new friends
and I had to do that and learn new
language and all of a sudden learn how
to have parents who were with me all the
time and I also had in my mind America
was this sort of
fairytail in a way it was this magical
place that I experienced through my
summer vacations of going to Six Flags
and SeaWorld and what I saw on
television so there were a couple of
shows that were dubbed in Spanish that I
watched in Mexico was Dennis the Menace
and Beverly Hills 902 100 like the
original version and everybody in those
shows was beautiful and rich and white
and I didn't I didn't realize that once
I moved to San Antonio there actually
we're people who look like me who were
American and but but living here my
experience were so different because
also my parents financial situation had
changed so much and so drastically so
and even things that I I had access to
before such as all the lessons that I
mentioned we couldn't afford that
anymore
the and it was very difficult to to
experience that and to see my parents
working so hard but at the same time it
was it was really eye-opening to me
because before that I never realized
just how hard and just how much my
parents were sacrificing in order for me
to have the life that I had but being
here I could see it firsthand and I
could see just how much they were
laboring I mean they were they were
working all the time all the time they
were working so hard that's of course
one of the things about being immigrants
in the United States and they were in a
situation where they actually they had
visas you had a visa to come to the
United States which is a bit different
than most other Mexicans coming to the
United States so you and and they had
had a successful business what happened
what happened that made the their
financial circumstances change so yeah
any what's interesting is this I
whenever I think we think of
undocumented people we always think of
people crossing the border but the
reality is that 40% of undocumented
immigrants in this country never crossed
the border illegally their visas expired
in my case it was that tourist visa that
that expired but what would happen
my parents business is that based import
sterling silver as I mentioned and they
had a pretty a pretty good routine of
getting the silver in Laredo Texas and
then going through customs and then
bringing it to San Antonio and in one of
those trips the silver that was in the
band was stolen and it was probably a
hundred thousand dollars worth of stolen
silver that was stolen on the US side of
the border and they were they were never
able to recover from that I'm always
amazed at how much my parents
accomplished with the resources that
they had my mom never graduated from
high school my dad finished high school
by going to night school and and so they
you know they accomplished so much and
they the best they could but there were
there were some things that they
probably didn't think about and and so
that ensuring that the silver that was
stolen wasn't insured and and so they
were just unable to recover after that
robbery and it wasn't for lack of trying
it was just a really difficult
circumstance that they that they found
themselves in what what did they do then
in order to make a living yeah so they
they took out and they took out a
mortgage and they try to rebuild the
silver business but it just wasn't it
wasn't the same and so my mom being the
relentless entrepreneurial woman that
she is so an opportunity to start
selling funnel cakes and start selling
snow cones and and all sorts of
different food items at festivals in San
Antonio we we used to go to those
festivals when we were little kids used
to take us and so she saw an opportunity
to start that business and and that's
what we started doing we started selling
the funnel cakes in San Antonio and you
were very much a part of that this was a
family enterprise in terms of working
when you could to help and so forth but
in the meanwhile you're in school you're
smart you're a very
studious disciplined student and McCool
is by and large a really hard experience
for you sixth grade you mentioned as
being one of the most terrible years of
your life and you become aware of being
Mexican talk about that talk about that
awareness and and what it meant to be
striving in school how others treated
you tell us how that felt yeah so you
know I think going back to what my idea
of America was right and only seen one
group of people portrayed on television
so feeling like I wasn't a part of that
and that experience came back when I was
learning about the civil rights movement
and the history that we tell in the
textbooks is a very it's it's from a
perspective of a black and white
narrative and so I never learned about
Latinos during the civil rights movement
and my parents never really talked to me
about racism and race in America and I
don't know if that was because they
didn't experience it or because they
thought that since I was growing up in
America and I was learning English and I
was quote assimilating that I wouldn't
have that experience but and and and in
learning about the civil rights movement
impacted me deeply and I used to cry to
my dad at when he picked me up from
school and tell him about all the
atrocities that I was learning about in
school but I didn't see myself in that
and so I didn't think that applied to me
but of course in sixth grade as you
mentioned there was a kid who when I was
placed in an honors math class asked a
question and he said why is she in the
honors math math class she's a Mexican
she can't even speak English and it took
everything I had not to cry and in my
broken English I said you you know I
don't need to learn how to speak English
to to do math math is a language
universal language and that's why I was
always so drawn to it because two plus
two is four and
language and so but but that experience
really even at that early age I
understood the issues that are in that
that are in our culture and I realized
that I may not be I may not have been
talked about in the textbooks but that
it was something that I was going to
experience in my life yes so that's an
awareness that you're now growing into
and having to deal with but you are
contending so you're contending with a
lot of emotional pressures as well as
just the social pressures of trying to
make friends and and and and do
schoolwork help your family and your
parents with their work but you're not
really at this point very aware of
immigration status or of what is to come
in terms of being illegally in the
country
talk talk take us forward to how that
came about how did you learn that what
what were the circumstances and how did
you understand that at the time yeah so
I you're right that I was not aware of
those immigration issues because I had
freely for a long time being able to go
back and forth between Mexico in the
u.s. so that was what was normal to me
and I thought that that was what would
be available to me always and when my
visa expired at the age of fourteen my
mother was very reluctant to talk to me
about that she was very reluctant to
tell me about my visa having expired and
once my visa was expired being unable to
renew it because of our financial
circumstances had changed and also
because it was a tourist visa and I had
been studying in the US and granted no
I'm a fourteen-year-old girl I never
asked to come here and Here I am now
having to understand what it means that
my visa is expired my mother tells me it
is because I was pushing her and pushing
her about planning my quinceanera my
15th birthday
which as grow growing up in tasco and
seeing my sisters have their
quinceaneras i dreamt of this of this
monumental thing in my life since I was
like three years old so I'm pushing my
mom and asking her to when are we gonna
go to Mexico to have this quinceanera
and I knew that our financial situation
had changed but I told my mom you know I
don't care if it's a small party I just
really want to have this experience in
my life and finally one day she just
blurted out that my visa had expired and
on that day that she told me this I
didn't fully comprehend the enormous
relevation she had made to me I couldn't
have understood the way in which that
one conversation was going to shaped and
impact the rest of my life I couldn't
have known
no you couldn't you couldn't have known
and and and it plays itself out then
over the subsequent years and I think
the in fascinating way in which you
write about it in the book is that it's
so totally tied up with the quinceanera
and the disappointment and I mean you
have you've said something but it about
how important that is in your culture
but I mean it's just so hugely important
in your culture that that kind of a
disappointment is almost you know I mean
one can't overstate what a
disappointment that would have been but
now you have this knowledge that you're
not supposed to be in this country and
so you're illegally in the country and
that's the beginning of the big secret
the big secret being such a critical
part then of your experience and and of
your story top try help people
understand just as a high school student
now why that became why that is such a
complication yeah there is there's a lot
that goes into your realizing that
you're undocumented and how much that
changes your how much has changes your
life all of the sudden in every decision
that you make
you have to think about your immigration
status and that becomes the center of
every decision that you make and you
also start to feel very ashamed I think
that's the right word I felt ashamed of
being undocumented I felt like God
somehow made me less than and and a lot
of that had to do with with the way that
the issue of immigration is talked about
in the media and the way that that that
the news cover the issue
I never heard stories of of undocumented
people who were graduating in the top 5%
of her high school class or who were
entrepreneurs and employed you as
citizens those aren't the stories that I
was hearing it was about illegal aliens
being being criminals and when I looked
at my parents and when I looked at
myself that narrative didn't didn't fit
me but that's how you start to think
about yourself it does something to your
psyche when someone's calling you
illegal because how can you as a person
be illegal but but you start to
internalize all of those things and just
there were so many things that to to
most people are just everyday things
that they don't have to think about
twice a lot of my classmates for example
we're getting ready to take drivers ed
and get their drivers licenses and I was
always getting questions about when I
was gonna take drivers ed and when I was
gonna get my driver's license and and so
you you you start having to tell this
little lie so that nobody finds out your
truth your secret and so even things
like that like not being able to get a
driver's license or when all of my
classmates were starting to think about
college for me thinking about college as
much as it was instilled in me from a
very early age that education is my
salvation and education is going to open
doors of opportunity and my parents did
everything possible to make sure that I
had the best education that I could have
but even though I was qualified to go to
any number of colleges when it
time came to apply I was rejected from
all of them because of my lack of a
nine-digit social security number yes
the way that you describe the issue of
applying and the blank that you had to
leave for Social Security number it does
capture in such a specific way the
things that we assume that you and
people like you could not assume just a
simple thing like being able to fill in
a social security number but you did
excel in high school and you worked
extraordinarily hard and it was against
some pretty difficult personal
circumstances in your home and with your
parents at that point so how did you get
into college yeah well one of the
biggest things that you and I keep going
back to my parents because I I can't
thank them enough for everything and for
how they how they raised me but one of
the things that my mom told me was that
there are a million things that you
cannot control and why focus on those
things you have to focus on the things
that you can't control and do your best
and the rest will fall into place and so
that's what I did in college I thought
you know if I if I don't if I don't
study hard and if I'm not disciplined
about my schoolwork then then then for
sure I'm not going to be able to get
into college or be able to go to a great
a great school and so I graduated in the
top 5% of my high school class didn't
know where I was going to go to college
as I walked across the the stage and my
cap and gown and my high school
graduation and and that was also
difficult because every student that
graduates and walks across the stage
they'll say over over the the loud mic
where they're going to school so-and-so
is graduating they're attending
such-and-such University in the fall and
when I walked across the stage it was
just
jalisa are say because I had no plans
for college and explaining that to my
classmates and even to my teacher
why wasn't I going to college when I had
the grades I had when I had the the
resume that I had was I mean I I almost
didn't want to have to close myself off
I there were days when I didn't even
feel like going to school because I
didn't want to have to answer those
questions again and again and again but
I was I was really fortunate because the
state of Texas in 2001 became the first
state in all of the u.s. to allow
undocumented students to go to college
pay in-state tuition and receive state
financial aid and 2001 is the year that
I graduated from high school and that
summer after graduation I learned of
this new law and I got in touch with the
state senator that was the sponsor for
the bill I told him told him and his
staff about my circumstances and whether
or not I would be able to go to school
that fall because I gotten rejected but
luckily they were able to send a letter
to the University of Texas at Austin
simply asking to reconsider my
application given this new law and
because my grades and my test scores and
everything else qualified me to be
accepted I received a letter two weeks
before the semester started that I was
accepted to the University of Texas at
Austin and it was one of the one of the
happiest days just knowing that finally
there was some reward for the hard work
that I had put in and for the hard work
that my parents had put in long before I
was even born well it is an incredible
story and the timing of and-and-and the
couple of angels that were sitting on
your shoulders one being the woman in
the Senators office who really took a
liking to you and made it her personal
project to be sure that this law that
had just passed could in fact apply
bright that next school year and the
other it seems to me was it was his name
mr. G your physics teacher you
just tell ya just tell a little bit of
it because he's the one that really got
you to you know make that call and so
alright just tell us a little bit about
mr. G because it is amazing the people
that are around in one's lives that just
make all the difference yeah
mr. Ness bilious is is my high school
teacher's name and I still keep in touch
with him he's he's been a great mentor
throughout throughout my life and in
high school he was this really quirky
teacher that would that would read us
stories even though this was like
physics but every every class he began
by telling us a story a motivational
story and then we would go into physics
class and he really encouraged me to
apply I never really told him out loud
I'm undocumented I don't have papers I
would just say you know we'll just say I
don't really think I can apply to school
and my parents find all such situations
really hard and you know my little
brother and I might have to just stay
home next year to help around the house
and help with my mom and he really
encouraged me he just said you know you
really have to apply they're gonna have
to let you in and I don't I don't know
if he knew and if he didn't know he
never made me feel embarrassed about it
he never pushed me to tell him more than
but now it was comfortable telling him
about and and he you know he really
encouraged me to to apply to all
different kinds of schools he would tell
me that his letters of recommendation
would have to get me in and if they
didn't then he didn't know what was
wrong with the world and and the
University of Texas at Austin is one of
the schools that he said this is a great
school it's a great program you have to
apply there and I didn't want to let him
down and and so I applied to all these
schools because because of him well then
it's and it's incredible to me oh sorry
go ahead
no I was just gonna say thank goodness
for people like that because that you
know he made you you made the difference
in your future yeah
so you're now at the University of Texas
you're at you know one of the top
schools in the country and you've chosen
to major in business and you're in one
of the top business schools in the
country
so you know there's the whole story then
of college and the people you meet and
your posse or your sort of six-pack
friends and so forth and and we won't go
into that because we want people to read
the book and read more about all of that
but I I think what's so striking about
your time in college to me was the sort
of deeper issues here of some themes
that really run through the book and one
of them is family how driven you are
were by your concerns about your family
and your closeness to your family and
the other is your incredible desire and
drive to earn money to have money and
and I wonder whether you could talk a
bit about that drive and about those two
parts of your life as they became really
forces during this time that you're in
college yeah my experience as a child I
saw I saw when I was when I was very
young living in Mexico I had a very nice
comfortable life then I moved to the US
and I see how much my parents are
struggling how much they're struggling
to make ends meet
and that really was instructive in my
life and and realizing that I didn't
want to struggle financially when I was
older and I wanted to be able to provide
for my family to provide for my mom and
my dad and for my little brother and and
that really drove me and I think when
you when you grow up and you don't have
it really drives you and it really
motivates you to work hard to to get
those things and for me financial
success was more than
and than just the money to me having
financial success was a way to earn my
way into America I thought that if I
could earn enough money then maybe
somehow I would be able to fix my
immigration status and maybe somehow I
would be accepted into America because
maybe I could earn my way into it
of course I was totally naive in that
thinking because that's not at all how
it works but that was my drive and and
that's what I work towards I worked
really hard because I thought I want to
get a great paying job and I didn't know
of course whether I could or not because
I was still undocumented but kept sort
of my mother's words in the back of my
mind of do the things that you that you
can and let the other things you can't
control let them play themselves out so
I focused a lot on on school and and and
yeah you're right that that financial
success was what what drove me but there
was so much behind that it wasn't just I
want to get rich it was it was all the
things that I could do once I had that
financial success well that's so clear
in the way that that the that you write
the book and in what it is that you do
with your you know with your ultimate
you know later financial success i i'm
gonna read just one paragraph that I
think captures it so well and really
describes how what you're up against
what you were facing it's on page 83 I
was ready to escape and by then it was
about much more than just the escape
from my unhappy home life going to
college was the next step in the
American dream I'd been taught to chase
I thought constantly about what it would
feel like to be someone important
successful and powerful I wanted to make
all kinds of money so I could solve all
of our problems I would finish the dream
home my parents had stopped building pay
for my father to go to rehab and pay for
Julio's education I would resolve my
and status so it wouldn't be an issue
anymore and I would rise above all the
challenges my family and I faced to live
the great promise that America gives to
so many if I were successful enriched
why would anyone want to turn me away
it's such a powerful set of ideas and
circumstances that you were dealing with
and trying to tackle and grapple with so
you're in college you turn out to be as
in high school an exceptional student
you're not only an exceptional student
in terms of grades you have friendships
but you're also working your way through
you're working hard for a while you're
commuting back and forth to San Antonio
doing funnel cakes on the weekend in
order to be able to pay for school and
then you recognize through the student
Hispanic student business organization
that you should be getting an internship
and so you're very savvy in getting an
internship and you manage to land in the
summer of your junior year I believe at
Goldman Sachs in New York so you have
this extraordinary internship this
tremendous opportunity but you're also
still dealing with the issue that you
don't have documents you're going to
have to go through background checks etc
and you get a job offer from them you
have the opportunity to be in a really
extraordinary mentorship program I want
you to talk to people in this audience
about what that was like being in New
York being at a top-flight firm like
Goldman Sachs and and for me it was in
many ways captured by this story that
has to do with never eating the shrimp
never don't ever eat the shrimp as a way
of illustrating what that culture was
like and what
work was like tell that story and use it
as an illustration of helping people to
understand what that life coming into
Goldman Sachs was like yeah it's working
at working at Goldman and having that
opportunity as you mentioned of
interning at Goldman for the summer was
just such an incredible opportunity and
it was also such a stark difference
between the worlds that I grew up in and
now the world of finance and the
pinnacle of Wall Street and you know you
were here to work and this this way
about donate the shrimp and we had the
opportunity to go to a lot of networking
events and through this mentorship
program the sponsors for educational
opportunities they taught us they taught
us a lot of technical things just from
like financial modeling but they also
taught us a lot about the interpersonal
relationships and how you handled
yourself in a business context and so
the big thing was even though there was
so many food and and and and as someone
who didn't grow up like that to seeing
all this like massive amount of food and
sure cocktails and just really fancy
things that I wasn't used to of course
you want to go and like take part in
that but but you were told no you were
there to network and you are there to
try to get a job so you don't eat the
shrimp you you need to have your
hands-free to be able to shake hands to
take people's business cards to write
notes in the back of those business
cards so that you can later thank them
with a personal note so you can send
them handwritten thank-you notes you
were there to network every every
networking opportunity in New York City
is is an opportunity to land a job to
nap to land your next deal to land your
next promotion even so that was the
culture that you lived in and you you
could never you could never turn off it
was never just having a drink so it
petitioned to learning those social
skills and learning to network
you were doing really intense work and
you were obviously very good at it why
would you what's your what were you
surprised at how successful you were
what is it you think that allowed you to
be so very successful at Goldman Sachs
as a young financial analyst well the
first the first thing is is that I've
always been taught to work hard that's
like the very first sort of base layer
thing that I must do I must do the work
and so I was the first one to come in
and the last one to leave and I worked
really really hard
I asked smart questions I know I did I
did research that maybe someone else
might not might not do and so I wasn't I
wasn't surprised at the success that I
had because I very much felt like I was
earning that success and I was working
really hard towards that success but you
know I was also incredibly fortunate to
have amazing mentors that taught me
things that I may have not known or they
told me things that I needed to look out
for they helped me to understand and
navigate the the political part of of
the business world because you can do
the work and you can be the best person
at your job but you still also have to
worry and think about navigating like I
said the political aspects of it who who
is going to speak up for you when there
are meetings about who's getting
promoted and when their meetings about
what the races are going to be what the
bonuses are going to be you want to make
sure that there's someone in that room
that it's advocating for you and so all
of those things I wouldn't have known if
it wasn't for the incredible mentors
that I had well you were in a situation
where there were four to several people
that really took care of you that really
helped you
as as you said but you also were a
Latina you were obviously females not
that many females in that business world
more but not nearly as no way parody or
anything like that at this point and you
were continuing to deal with this
incredible secret and always concern
about whether it might catch up with you
at some point so perhaps talk a little
bit about when you actually got the job
offer after the internship came to New
York moved to New York had an apartment
and were facing the first day of going
to work and knowing that you yet again
we're going to have to deal with
documents background checks and so forth
what happened to you yeah that day was
really scary because I had already I had
already passed the background check and
but on that first day of analyst
training as you do in any in any new job
you have to fill out your tax form and
you have to give two copies of ID and so
I didn't know whether my my documents
were going to stand out if they were
going to look different than everybody
else's real documents and so it was a
really it was a really scary day I mean
I was I was so nervous that and so
scared and you know this fear that you
live in when you're undocumented always
having to hide always having to live
your life in the shadows always worried
and scared that someone might find out
and and you might get deported and and
and everything you've worked so hard for
is just going to poof and disappear so
it it's it it's really it was so much
that that if I wasn't dealing with it
emotionally because I still had to
present myself in a professional manner
it definitely came out in in in a
physical way with me I mean I had awful
headaches and back pain and and all
sorts of ailments at a very young age
because of the incredible stress that I
was under of having to keep this secret
while at the same time trying to stand
out with my work so there was always
this push and pull of I want to go
really fast and I want to get promoted
and I want to stand out and at the same
time having to take a step back because
you don't want to get noticed because
you don't want to get found out so it
was a lot it was a lot to deal with and
on that issue of documents I tell us
because people don't really it's hard to
fathom how somebody that doesn't have
documents in fact can fill out those
forms and the level of scrutiny that is
or isn't given to it what documents did
you have yeah so I had I still had a
Social Security card and a green card
but those documents were fake and when I
think back to making that decision of
getting those papers
it was a really difficult decision to
make and and and I and I hope that that
that we can all relate to having to make
really difficult choices and decisions
in our lives I think all of us at one
point have been faced with those kinds
of decisions where there just isn't a
right answer and so you do the best you
can and you move forward and and that
was 19 years old when I when I made the
decision to purchase this fake documents
the funnel cake stand that I had had to
be shut down because the city of San
Antonio built a museum and and then I
was then I had to make a decision do I
drop out of school or do I get a job and
continue to find ways to pay for school
and that's the decision that I had made
and so those are the documents that I
that I used to a few years later apply
for this job at Goldman Sachs and
you know I I don't know how these
documents work they were they were they
were fake
to the truest sense of the word that
they didn't belong to anyone I wasn't
stealing someone's identity
they were completely made-up numbers and
somehow and somehow they worked and when
you go through a background check
they're checking for a criminal
background which which I of course
didn't have and and and I think the
other the other aspect of this is that
because we have this idea in our mind of
who undocumented people are the jobs
that we do no one was really going to
question my documents right I I had
graduated from a top five Business
School in the country
I was professional I was I was I was
polished because of all the mentoring
that I had that I had gone through so
when I presented my papers no one was
gonna really look at them and say are
these papers real right it was more of a
check the box as they did with everybody
else on that day at analyst training and
what you're describing of course is that
from all external characteristics
you weren't the stereotype and you
weren't in the settings where any kind
of preconceived notion would have come
into play and it is a very there's a lot
to think about in in in in that reality
so you managed to get through these
things and you managed and you're
obviously now doing very well at Goldman
you're promoted you're getting at a
certain point very substantial salary
increases you're from all external
indications really on the path to
success and you're doing extremely well
and as much as that's the case on the
outside it's very different on the
inside very much on the inside you're
having different emotions
different reactions to all of us
describe to us that those contradictions
yeah yeah we on one hand my story and my
journey was the definition of the
American dream right coming from the
background that I came in and working
really hard and moving up the economic
ladder and on the other hand I couldn't
have been farther away from the
definition of the American dream because
I wasn't legally part of what defines
American and I always had to to balance
those two ideas in my mind you know on
one hand I had financial resources that
I understand aren't available to to a
lot of people in our country and on the
other hand even though I had those
financial resources I was so limited in
the things that I could do I still
couldn't I still couldn't drive with a
valid driver's license I saw I couldn't
have a credit card
I couldn't even invest my own money even
though I was working in the financial
industry and I was working with
investments and I couldn't apply those
things to my own personal life because
of my immigration status so there was
always is as you said these
contradictions in my life and and in
some ways they kept me grounded and in
other ways there were just constant
reminders constant reminders that I
wasn't I wasn't really a part of the
fabric and the makeup of our country and
I couldn't contribute fully as I wanted
to well and then of course you had the
very sad circumstances of your father
dying and of your grandmother dying and
you weren't able to go home and see them
either go to their funerals or be with
them in their last days because the fact
of you're not having status in the
United States made it impossible to come
back and you would have had to
abandon what was at this point really a
successful few possible future so you
know you then ultimately meet somebody
you get married that person is an
American citizen that makes it possible
for you to adjust your status you're
only able to do so because you came here
on a visa and that gets into a
technicality which we you know don't
won't won't be able to really pursue but
you were among the lucky people that was
a that that have been able to adjust
status and you've now become a citizen
and and in the process a lot of personal
journey was taking place a lot of
changes in your own thinking that led
you to leave the financial industry so
you've left the financial industry and
you're now really developing an entirely
new chapter in your life talk to us
about writing this book and this
personal story which is in many ways a
story of triumph it's also a story of
deep pain why are you telling it I
realized that I had a powerful story to
tell the kind of story that could really
have an impact on the dialogue that we
have around really important issues of
immigration and of immigrants that my
story could give hope to the millions of
people who are still living in the
reality that I lived in for so long and
I felt a really deep sense of
responsibility to share that story and
and to keep the ladder so that other
people can climb up in and to reach down
and bring people up with me and and
writing this book you know I wrote an
outline nine years ago of the book that
I would one day right and there was some
about a month after my dad passed away
and I remember that
entry talking about that one day I'm
going to use this pain and this
suffering and it's all going to mean
something and it's all going to be for
something and and writing this book is
the result of that wild aspiration that
I had nine years ago and telling my
story has been incredibly at a personal
level it has been incredibly freeing to
finally be able to say this is my truth
and this is my story and on a bigger
broader level I hope that it validates
the experience and the feelings and the
fear that millions of people are facing
because it can be very lonely feeling
that way without having anyone else that
you can relate to and you feel like
you're alone in this world and you're
the only person that is experiencing
those things and knowing that there are
other people helps tremendously and so I
have really high hopes for this book I
really hope that people are able to pick
up a copy and find themselves in my
experience and hopefully I've been able
to create enough human connections that
we can if we haven't if someone's not
undocumented or they don't consider
themselves an immigrant at all I still
really think that this book is it's an
American story even beyond being a story
about an immigrant it's interesting that
in coming to grips with this new future
that you're putting together this issue
of loneliness does come through so
clearly that even at the level of
sophistication and success that you were
operating you actually weren't nearly as
aware as you probably are now about how
many other people share that story and
all of the grassroots effort and
activity that has begun to develop in
recent years around people like you not
entirely like you because you've had a
very exceptional success story here but
you are really finding a whole different
community of people to connect with from
what I can see is that am I
am i right in that yeah you are and in
some ways in a lot of ways I feel like
I'm a little bit late to to the game
here because I am just in the last two
three years really immerse myself in to
the the fight for immigrant rights and
and but there have been so many people
that have for a long time before I I
came out with my story that have been
working tirelessly their entire lives to
provide more rights to immigrants and to
change the conversation around
immigration and to fight for people to
live with with dignity and and to be
seen with dignity and so and and you
know my my my experience is different
because everybody's experience is how
unique and different of course and it
was and it was sometimes easy to forget
right like being in my apartment on Wall
Street it was easy to forget that there
were people who were struggling so much
more than I was and and now being a part
of this world and hearing the stories
every single day hearing from people who
are living who are leaving those
experiences is it's incredibly emotional
and I feel so proud to be able to be a
part of this community and and to know
that I'm not alone anymore I'm not alone
in the experience that I had and I'm not
alone in the work that I'm trying to do
and and the things that I'm trying to
achieve now well it is it you know
talking about changing the conversation
I do want to give you the opportunity to
say something about this election season
that we're in and the way in which
immigration is being described
particularly the 11 million people in
the country who don't have legal status
what would you want them to be hearing
given the public debate that's currently
taking place yeah that this the the
narrative in this election and the
the rhetoric in this election has been
and it is incredibly harmful and
dangerous and is factually incorrect
because the the story that we hear is
that 11 million immigrants are the
reason and the source of all of our
country's problems and that if we just
get rid of them
that there will be no more problems in
America and of course I couldn't be
further from the truth and in fact when
I think about immigrants and why we come
here I always I always have this thought
in my mind that immigrants are willing
to risk their very lives they are
willing to cross oceans and
walk-throughs asserts and leave
everything behind because that's how
much they believe in America that's how
much they believe that they can come to
this country in search of a better life
and if we wanted to just get by and get
on welfare as many people believe we
would have just stayed where we were
that's not why we come here and getting
rid of 11 million people it's not only
the humanizing rhetoric but when you
think about just from an economic
standpoint if from one day to the next
your population shrinks by 11 million
people and 11 million people don't go to
work tomorrow an 11 million people
aren't buying things and paying sales
taxes and creating economic activity
that is going to have a deep impact in
the economy of our country so not only
is deporting 11 million people not a
solution it actually would create
significant economic problems for
Americans well
jalisa this has been an amazing time to
spend with you very very best wishes and
thank you so much for writing this book
about your story thank you so much for
having me